This is a weird one.
What if our entire universe is inside a black hole?
I mean that literally.
What if everything we can see,
from the galaxy to the star, planet,
even you sitting there watching this,
is actually on the inside of a black hole
that exists in some much larger universe?
Now, I know what you're probably thinking.
How's that even possible?
Because when we think about a black hole,
we usually picture this giant dark object
somewhere out in space, pulling everything toward it.
But that's not really what a black hole is.
And once you understand that,
this whole idea starts getting a lot more interesting.
You see, a black hole is basically a region of space
where gravity has become so extreme
that once you cross a certain boundary,
you just can't get back out.
And I mean anything.
You could have the fastest spaceship imaginable,
and it wouldn't even matter.
Nothing can escape this, not even light.
And that boundary is called the event horizon.
Now, here's something that's kind of surprising.
The event horizon isn't a wall.
You don't reach it and suddenly hit
some giant invisible barrier.
If you were falling into a really massive black hole,
you could actually cross this event horizon
without noticing some dramatic change
at that exact moment.
The problem is what happens after,
because according to Einstein's theory of general relativity,
once you're inside, all possible paths forward
eventually lead deeper into the black hole.
And if you keep following that path,
the equations eventually take you
to something called a singularity.
So what's a singularity?
It's basically where our current equations
stop making sense.
They start producing infinities.
And whenever physicists get an infinity like that,
they don't usually celebrate and say,
well, that's obviously what nature does.
No, they tend to think,
okay, something is missing.
And that's where things get really interesting,
because we have two incredibly successful theories.
General relativity tells us how gravity and space-time behave,
and quantum mechanics tells us how the very small behaves.
But inside a black hole,
eventually you get into a situation
where you need both theories at the same time,
and we still don't have a complete theory
that combines them.
So honestly, we don't know what the deepest part
of a black hole actually looks like.
So the question then is,
what if that singularity isn't really the end?
What if something happens there
that our current physics simply doesn't know
how to describe yet,
or doesn't even know it exists?
Maybe quantum gravity prevents everything
from collapsing into an actual infinite point,
or maybe the collapse reaches some incredibly extreme state
and then transitions into something else.
Because what if it starts expanding again
and even ends up creating
a completely new region of space-time,
something like a new universe?
Now just think about that for a second.
Let's say you're living in some giant parent universe.
A massive star collapses and it forms a black hole.
From your perspective, you look at it and say,
there's a black hole.
But inside that black hole,
suppose a new expanding region of space-time forms.
The people living inside that region
wouldn't necessarily see a black hole.
They'd see galaxies, stars, and planets.
These people would see an expanding universe,
and eventually they'd probably ask the same question we ask,
where did all of this come from?
And their answer could be what they call the Big Bang.
That's the basic idea I'm trying to draw your attention to.
Now, before you get too excited,
there's something I really want to make clear.
Scientists have not discovered
that our universe is inside a black hole.
Actually, there's no evidence right now that proves that.
It's just a speculative idea.
But it's also interesting
because it connects to a real problem in physics.
We don't actually know what happens
at the deepest point inside a black hole,
and that's a pretty big hole in our understanding.
Now let's talk about the Big Bang
because there's another thing people often get wrong here.
When you hear Big Bang,
you might imagine the universe as this tiny ball
that exploded outward into empty space.
That's not really what happened.
There wasn't an empty room called space sitting there
while the universe exploded inside it.
Space itself was expanding.
You see, the early universe was incredibly hot
and incredibly dense,
and as space expanded, the universe cooled down.
So if a black hole really could somehow produce a new universe,
we're not talking about a black hole going boom.
No, it's something much stranger.
The inside of that black hole
would somehow become a new expanding space time.
Do you get it?
And if you lived inside that space time,
you'd experience that expansion as the history of your universe,
which then raises a pretty uncomfortable question.
If we're inside a black hole,
where is the event horizon?
Where's the edge?
And why don't we see some giant black sphere
surrounding the universe?
Well, this is where our everyday intuition
doesn't really help.
Remember, an event horizon isn't a physical wall.
It's a boundary in space time
that basically tells you
which events can still communicate with the outside
and which ones can't.
So you wouldn't necessarily look through a telescope
and see a big black circle around the universe.
There might not be anything visually obvious to see.
The boundary here is part of the geometry of space time itself,
and that means something really strange could be true.
We could, in principle, be inside such a region
without being able to look around
and recognize it as a black hole.
Now, here's an analogy.
Let's imagine a creature
that can only move across a flat sheet of paper.
It can go left and right,
and it can move forward and backward,
but it has no concept of up.
Now, imagine you, standing above the paper,
pick that creature up and move it somewhere else.
From the creature's perspective,
you just did something completely impossible.
Unbeknownst to the creature,
you didn't break any of the rules of its world.
You simply used a direction that it couldn't access.
That's roughly the kind of intuition we need
when thinking about higher dimensional
or larger space-time structures.
I'm not saying our universe is literally a sheet of paper.
It's just a way to understand why.
Something can look completely impossible
from one perspective and perfectly normal from another.
And now we get to the question
that really makes this idea uncomfortable.
What's outside our universe?
Normally, that question doesn't even make sense, right?
If the universe is everything that exists,
then what's outside it?
Nothing.
But suppose our universe is actually the inside of a black hole.
Then maybe there is a larger space-time outside of ours,
a kind of parent universe.
And now just imagine someone in that parent universe
looking at our black hole.
They might see an event horizon
and might even measure its mass.
They might watch matter orbiting around it
and they'd say,
that's a black hole.
Meanwhile, inside,
we're looking around and saying,
this is the universe.
It's the same structure,
just two completely different perspectives.
And that's the part I find really fascinating
because maybe the word universe
doesn't necessarily mean the absolute biggest thing that exists.
Maybe it just means the region of space-time
we're able to experience.
Now, could we ever prove that we're inside a black hole?
That's where things get difficult.
The thing is,
if the outside is genuinely beyond our causal horizon,
we can't just build a bigger telescope and look out.
It wouldn't matter how powerful the telescope was.
And this is because if information can't reach us from outside,
there's absolutely nothing for the telescope to see.
So we'd have to look for indirect evidence.
Maybe the way our universe expanded contains some clues,
or there could be particular patterns
in the cosmic microwave background.
Who knows?
Maybe the geometry of our universe
would have some unusual features
or a future theory of quantum gravity
would make a very specific prediction that we could test.
That's how we'd have to approach it scientifically.
We may get to a point where we'd need a prediction that says,
if we're inside a black hole,
we should observe this or that.
And if we don't see it,
the idea gets weaker.
That's the difference between an interesting thought experiment
and a scientific theory.
But right now,
we don't have the smoking gun
and black holes already give physicists another headache.
Information.
This is one of the deepest problems in modern physics.
I want you to think of throwing a book into a black hole.
This book contains information.
I mean, every word, letter, molecule, everything about its physical state.
Quantum mechanics tells us that information is incredibly important.
It shouldn't simply disappear from reality.
But according to the classical picture of a black hole,
that book falls past the event horizon and eventually reaches the singularity.
So what happens to all that information?
Then Stephen Hawking made the problem even worse.
He discovered that black holes should actually emit radiation.
It's called Hawking radiation.
So a black hole isn't completely black.
It can slowly lose energy and over an unbelievably long period of time,
it could eventually evaporate.
Okay.
So now imagine the black hole disappears.
What happened to the information in the book?
Where did it go?
Did it somehow come back out through the Hawking radiation?
Was it encoded in the radiation in some incredibly complicated way?
Or is there something about our understanding of space-time
that we're fundamentally missing?
Physicists have been wrestling with this for decades.
And this is why black holes are so important.
They're not just weird objects that eat stars.
They're basically nature's way of forcing our best theories to collide
from gravity to quantum mechanics, information, space, time, just name them.
And right now we don't have the complete answer,
which brings us back to our original question.
What if our universe is inside a black hole?
Maybe, maybe not.
We don't even know.
And I think that's actually more interesting than pretending we have an answer
because if it were true, the Big Bang might not have been the beginning of everything.
Or it might have been the beginning of our universe.
There could be something before it or something outside it.
Maybe even another universe.
And here's where you can take the idea one step further.
What if black holes don't just create one universe?
What if they can create many?
I mean, I'm just thinking out loud.
Just imagine a universe.
Stars form and some eventually die or collapse into black holes.
And if these speculative models were correct,
perhaps some of those black holes end up producing new universes.
And those universes form stars.
Those stars then form more black holes.
And those black holes potentially produce even more universes.
And you'd have this huge cosmic family tree
where a universe could have a parent and that parent could have a parent.
And maybe there was something before that.
Now, again, we have no evidence that this cosmic family tree actually exists.
This isn't established science.
But it raises a really beautiful question.
Maybe the universe isn't a single isolated thing.
Who knows?
Maybe reality is much bigger than the part we're able to experience.
And maybe what we call the beginning of the universe
is actually just the beginning of our particular corner of reality.
So are we inside a black hole?
Right now, there's no way for me to honestly tell you yes.